à montigny le bretonneux un duel à trois
listes se profile pour ce scrutin pierre
déjean bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes la tête
de liste de montigny solidarité 2020 une
candidature de gauche pour vous qui êtes
ancien conseiller municipal ans dans la
commune de montigny le bretonneux vous
êtes aussi engagé dans l'associatif
locale vous avez siéger au sein du
conseil municipal de 2008 à 2014
pourquoi vous vous engagez dans cette
campagne des municipales
mais pourquoi parce que il faut que la
gauche sur présente sebring un otni
bretonneux tout simplement
et au regard de ce qui se passait dans
les veaux début de l'année il apparut
que bon il y avait quelques difficultés
de ses côtés là et puis j'ai rencontré
un ami que je connais depuis quelques
années et qui de gauche aussi puisque
les clones labaki et président de la pop
secrétaire pendant de la section
socialiste de montigny et il m'a dit bon
écoute faut qu'on discute produits
municipal donc haut la presse assez
embrouillée on s'est vu on a trouvé
quelques personnes en plus et puis de
fil en aiguille on a monté une liste
donc ça c'est important pour vous
défendre ses valeurs de gauche dans une
commune qui est plutôt
traditionnellement de centre-droit entre
calais et les maires qui sont jeunes et
lance les dernières années sont devant
ses droits c'est vrai sur les mers
enfin le conseil municipal bien entendu
c'est pas forcément vrai sur toutes les
élections il ya des élections où la
gauche était majoritaire et donc là il
ya un problème il faut au niveau
municipal aussi la gauche se trouve sa
majorité
et c'est ce que nous avons essayé de
faire alors si nice qui partent
finalement seul il y avait des
discussions qui étaient en cours avec
une autre liste m qui est menée par un
conseiller municipal d'opposition libyen
gas qui a huit ou de tout à fait on a
de nombreuses réunions de discussion
pour savoir puisqu'ils ont un programme
qui est un peu serait même n'est que
nous mais là où il ya eu le
l'achoppement c'est effectivement sur la
qualification de gauche puisque ça a
posé des problèmes
on est d'aider des discussions on avait
trouvé qu'on a commencé à trouver un
terrain d'entente
et puis tout d'un coup au feu ce terrain
d'entente a disparu nous non pas
question de mettre la gauche nous on est
pas on se qualifie pas comme ça ils ont
choisi des visions où ils ont choisi
l'option déroulera à nice qui se veut un
peu plus ouverte pour votre liste verte
oui mais ouverte vers quoi avait requis
on aura le clasico c'est l'agression il
ya des gens de plusieurs partis mais il
y aussi beaucoup de gens et la plupart
qui ne sont pas mandat partie d'accord
et qui sont dans l'associatif ou dans
leur vin tout ce qu'on veut mais mais
par contre qu'ils ont effectivement
qu'ils partagent avec nous de fortes
valeurs de gauche y est justement est-ce
que vous revendiquez une investiture pas
du tout est ce que vous êtes ouvert à
d'éventuels soutiens pour cette élection
pas revendiquer d'investiture d'aucun
parti même ceux pour le ceux qui en sont
membres
par contre nous acceptons effectivement
les soutiens ça je dirais que chacun est
libre de ses choix
charbonnier est maître chez soi dit non
et bien si les partis politiques de
gauche veulent nous soutenir woods
acceptera bien entendu mais nous ne
demandons pas d'investiture avant de
parler de vos priorités lui en a trois
pour cette campagne votre regard sur le
mandat qui va s'achever prochainement
celui de 2014 à 2020 avec comme maire
michel laugier d'abord qui est devenu
sénateur puis agent du congo tout à fait
on a eu droit d'ailleurs à la
présentation de la candidature de ce
marqueur
l'autre jour un candidat de la majorité
me soigne compte des dates de thau
droite un beau c'est un boucher de mario
quand même bien fait et on expliquer que
monsieur abou avait pris monsieur logés
comme une chef de cabinet et monsieur
auger devenue mère et puis monsieur j ai
choisi monsieur marcatté monsieur ma
carte l'ambition de devenir madrid
on attend avec impatience qu'elle est le
quel sera le nom du prochain sur le fond
demanda sur ce qui a pu être sur le fond
c'est donc c'est plutôt de la
communication beaucoup de communication
ils sont très forts par contre pour les
réalisations c'est un peu moins un peu
moins vous promener dans les rues de
montigny c'est pas nos propres été
exemplaire et un certain nombre de
locaux publics ailleurs particulier les
maisons de quartiers qui sont dans un
état lamentable
donc il me dit beaucoup de choses sur
montigny la ville qui voit bien je crois
qu'il ya quand même de ce côté là
beaucoup de choses à améliorer pour ce
soit vraiment eu une ville qui nous
avait bien alors trois priorités
on va parler d'avoir de la démocratie
locale comment faire partager justement
les citoyens les faire aussi participer
davantage à 7 alors démocratie locale de
tes fesses c'est une un problème auquel
nous avons à avoir à nous affronter
parce que la démocratie la participation
des chaudes des citoyens c'est pas
quelque chose d'évident
ne serait-ce que quand on regarde les
élections il ya beaucoup de citoyens qui
s'abstiennent donc c'est vraiment
quelque chose
un vrai challenge alors nous avons
d'abord décidé que les conseils de
quartiers seraient modifiées et
revivifié est par exemple c'est plus
qu'un symbole
beaucoup plus qu'un symbole le président
de la commission de quartier sera élu
élu par les membres de la commission et
non plus d amener lui désigné par le
maire je veux dire que ça c'est un
exemple mais on peut avoir aussi des
commissions sur un thème précis donc
on est très en place et puis quand le
thème sera clos comme la solution aura
été trouvée la commission disparaîtra
une autre sur un projet autres quelques
unes des pistes alors loïc l'autre
priorité deuxième priorité qui est une
valeur traditionnellement à gauche mais
que l'on retrouve constamment maintenant
un an cette campagne des municipales
c'est l'écologie on ne peut pas faire ça
aujourd'hui presque quels sont vos
projets propres propositions parmi eux
effectivement on ne peut pas faire ça
j'en profite d'ailleurs pour indiquer
que notre liste
bien sûr s'occupera essentiellement des
problèmes techniques montas mais que
nous estimons que ces problèmes ne sont
pas indépendants de ce qui se passe dans
le monde d'enfants bien sûr et dans le
monde entier le problème de surchauffe
mans climatique va toucher le monde
entier le monde entier alors évidemment
nous n'allons pas résoudre nous à nous
tout seul le cette question là mais on a
un certain nombre de choses que l'on
peut proposer sur visualisation des
bâtiments publics encore une fois je
vous reprends les évêques maison de
quartier parce que ou des coûts
certaines écoles qui ne sait pas qui
sont des passoires qui sont des
passoires
nous allons avoir essayé en tout cas de
mettre en place à 100 de cellules
photoélectriques sur les sur les soirs
sur les toits et d'ailleurs j'ai vu il
ya quelques jours sur un je suis plus ou
sur un de vos confrères écrit qu'une
société avait mis au point et c'était
très intéressant des cellules qui
permettent de récupérer à la fois
l'énergie solaire directeur pour
transformer les précités et la chaleur
alors que aujourd'hui ces deux types de
ce différend donc ça c'est une annonce
des déchets valorisés alors qu'on va
creuser de ce côté là je la garde pour
l'instant oui ça vient d'où ça vient de
sortir donc j'ai pas plus d'informations
que ça mais on va causer de ce côté là
parce que d'abord un il n'y a que les
rénergie que l'on ne produit pas qui ne
pollue pas donc il va falloir se
sa sainteté les réductions drastiques de
consommation d'énergie néanmoins on en a
besoin et donc voix pour cela il faut
chercher tous les moyens
d'abord de produire de l'énergie sans
avec le moindre effet sur le changement
climatique
et puis récupéré tout un tas de
d'énergie qui sont perdus et que vous
pourrez utiliser un dernier mois en 30
secondes paris on arrive à la fin de
cette intronisation votre dernier volet
la solidarité oui la solidarité parce
que c'est le crois que c'est un élément
fondamental de la du vivre ensemble
aujourd'hui par exemple on a un peu
tendance à mettre des gens dans des
cases les jeunes les vieux les actifs
les chômeurs d'autres comme ça et
qu'après tout on peut cumuler plusieurs
plusieurs cases et je crois qu'il faut
mettre ensemble et jean folly faire
rencontrer celles à base de démocratie
de citoyenneté
on aura l'occasion de reparler un de vos
votre programme sur cette antenne et je
précise aussi qu on retrouve comme pour
tous les autres candidats à montigny le
bretonneux dans les autres communes des
yvelines
votre agent date campagne sur le site
internet de tv 78 ans comme merci pierre
déjean il est repassé en plateau de tête
de liste de montigny à solidarité 2020
et deux autres listes au moins seront
également en cours celle de laura un
merker candidat de la majorité sortante
inhumans telle est la liste m conduite
pour l'instant pour un bis par un binôme
avec le conseiller municipal
d'opposition vilain gas et caroline ce
chaos